my name is dave walker i'm the field
application specialist for gcms and ms
and today we're going to spend a little
bit of time
uh going through quite a bit of
information actually we're going to try
to cover
uh two distinct applications uh epa
method five two one point one
and tetra through oxid-fluorinated
dioxins and purines by isotope deletions
so not only are we gonna try to cover
two methods we're gonna try to cover
five instruments and all in 25 minutes
so we're going to hope to have some
questions at the end if not please feel
free
to put them in the q a box and i will
get back to you
shortly after the after the presentation
so the first method i'd like to discuss
today is the nitrosamines analysis
and drinking water method 521
so determination of nitrosamines and
drinks and water by solid phase
extractions and capillary column gas
chromatography by 521
and the reason that we're doing this is
the apa has proposed increased testing
for nitrosamines
due to the reoccurrence in drinking
water and wastewater and we're going to
focus today on the ndma
we use traditional methodology requires
large volume injections and chemical
ionization
and the use of liquid ci and the tandem
mass spectrometer
that has been the gold standard for a
very long time for how to do this
methodology
the ion trap gcms traditionally is
recommended for 521
however since we acquired varian and
this was their my uh primary instrument
of choice we found that we can
move a lot of these types of analysis
onto the triple quad platform and get
comparable or better results so we've
decided to obsolete those
particular product line
the apa office of groundwater and
drinking water uh considered all the
detection limits without changing the
guidelines for sample preparation and
while maintaining
the detected limits
so we considered alternate detection
limits and what we did is we proposed
using the 7000 gc msms
and the 7010 gcms ms
for the alternate techniques
agilent directly compared to 2g csms
systems with the ion chat method and
we're dead by using three separate
laboratories
using duplicate sample sets sent to each
laboratory
uh today we're going to try to present a
in a more
detailed
setting uh excellent 7010 gcm sms versus
the variant 4000 gc iron trap
testing moves it forward again using the
three separate
laboratories for this study
uh the one compound you can see that
these are compounds that we're gonna uh
that we presented in this presentation
with the exception of mnor because
during the process
we had a contamination that was
observed in all three laboratories so
that particular compound will not be
part of this study
so we use the traditional we did not
change the
extractions method uh methylene chloride
methanol reagent water 500 ml of water
samples
uh methylene chloride soap
sodium sulfate water meth and then we
split the samples and sent them to each
of the laboratories
in the study
so traditionally this is how the ion
trap system would work we would use a
large volume injection in order to get
the sensitivity that we need
up to 10 microliters of injection volume
we'd have a split bend of 100 ml per
minute at point eight minutes
we'd use a four millimeter double
tapered ui layer
uh we did in
the particular laboratory that ran
the variant system for us
had an rtx 5 still column a 30 meter
0.25
1.0 micron film thickness
and you can see on the right hand side
they used a chemical ionization and
their run time was 40 minutes
and they had
detected at 40 ppt all of the compounds
of interest
there was some challenge
in the 40-minute run
with these particular peak resolutions
for chromatographic reasons
now the gcms 7010 system
one of the advantages you'll see right
away is that we can make a one
microliter injection versus a hundred
micro uh a ten microliter restriction
so we also use the four millimeter
double tapered liner
we used a db 1701 a 30 meter 0.25 still
at one micron film thickness golem
and we ran it into the uh msms system
now you can see that our total run time
is only 15 minutes
versus 40 minutes
which almost triples the capacity of
your laboratory
we were able to run the same class of
compounds at the 40 ppt level and we
were able to resolve everything to
baseline separation
and our run for the last compound of
interest was actually 4.9 minutes so we
could have had a run under 13 minutes we
chose to extend it out to 15.
here's the sample at 0.5 ppt
nitrosamines and sample with in a water
extract
and you can see that we still have very
good detections and the ndma comes out
around seven minutes
the internal standard is not
plotted because it's a 20 ppt
and it overwhelms the samples at the .05
ppt level so in order to give you the
uh best view of what the actual analytes
look like
we did not purposely
plot
the internal standards although that
they were
inserted into the samples
this is how our mrms worked so we had a
quantifier iron a qualifier ions we had
two of each
uh so that you had the ndma surrogates
all the compound of interest and then
you have the nvpa
d14 internal standard so surrogate and
internal standard and then the compounds
of interest
now we used as i mentioned we were going
to talk about
two
five instruments we're going to talk
about three here we already talked about
the variant iron trap briefly
and we're going to talk about the 7000
extractor source and the 7010
high efficiency source and here's the
basic uh structure of the two and you
can see that there's quite a difference
in the source
and that
between a standard non-extractive source
you can expect to have about 10 times
more ions created than you do
with a standard ion source because it
has an extractor lens so not only is it
using the propeller
to repel the ions out of the source it's
using the extractor to pull at the same
time
this empties the source faster and
allows us to create
and ionize more of the molecule
now the extra
high efficiency source
actually
uses instead of a sideways shot with the
uh filament it uses a vertical long way
shot with the filament so we're able to
ionize even more
we have to have this big case around the
outside is a magnet because we have to
spin the electrons around the entire
length of the ion volume
so this allows us to create even more
ions than the extractor source probably
somewhere in the factor of about eight
times more than the extractor source and
the extractor source was about a factor
of 10
more
than the traditional non-extractor
source
so let's take a look at some of the data
that we have here so here
the 7010
shows better performance than the 7000
but the 7000 you'll see in a minute
has better performance still than the
varian
ion track which has been traditionally
used
and here you can see that we've overlaid
the
qualifier ion and the quantifier ion and
you can see for ndma
that we have at 0.5 ppt
nitrosamines in the extract
very good
easily deceived way better than two and
a half times single to noise for each of
the compounds listed
and even at the 7000 you still have
better than two and a half times the
noise
but because of we're creating more ions
and we have the selectivity there you'll
see the difference between the 7000 and
the 70 10. again both systems
can perform the analysis but i see that
there's a clear benefit in the 7 to 10
system versus the 7000 system they both
use the same data system processing
so the familiarity between the two
is very good
here's the other compounds that were
listed in this compound so you can see
again here the 7000 performs very well
for these compounds and the 70 10
has an increase in area accounts for
each one again at the 0.5 ppt level
and finally here is our final compounds
that we looked at
and you can see again we have really
good uh in both systems are able to to
uh identify the
compounds of interest
and you can see on the npyr there is a
co-eluding peak there but because our
sensitivity is clearly
uh
above two and a half times similar noise
we're able to identify this compound
both with the qualifier and the
quantifier
our curves generally were point nine
nine
seven nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine nine
uh the ndma on the 7000 was the only one
that was not 0.995 it was 0.9935
however the methodology calls for 0.99
in this particular method we used 11
calibration points from 0.0
65
up to 100 ppt so we had quite a bit of
linear range
for this compounds as well
and again here's a brief summary just so
you can look at the laboratories
so you had a 70 10 run at laboratory a
70 10 month laboratory b
and a 7 000 ran at laboratory c
and you can see that across the board
you have very very similar results with
some improvement in the 7010
so here is the lcmr and the detection
limits on the ion trap versus the msms
so
uh in this particular case the lower
number is a better number because we're
having a lower detection limit
and a lower lc mrl
and at this case we were reading spike
ranges from 0.1 to 10 ppt
here's the 7010
is in the blue
the 7010 is also in the gold
and the 7000
is in the green
and you can see that the detection limit
that the mrl that we needed to receive
was above two and we're almost below one
for all of the compounds except for the
ndpa which was
barely at 1.2
and the detection limits for those as
well
we make all the detection limits for the
interlab study
well below
the detection limits assets find in the
method 521
and the ranges for the replicate samples
0.1
uh 210
and lab c from 1 to 10.
now these are the folks that helped uh
with the studies and
published the app note which is
available and you can see it here
uh so it's andy eaton
at the eurofins lab
the another european vladimir analytical
in south mainland indiana ralph indole
and fogon lab
i'd like to specifically thank ron
honnold diana wong and craig marvin
for putting this application known
together and supplying these slides
so
in summary for this
we did a method performance was verified
by three separate labs
the epa has provided the letter of
method equivalency for
the msms systems
the techniques equivalency
that for the 521 method
here's the application note number which
makes it easier for you to find so you
don't have to search through
google and look it up you could just put
in this part number and this application
note will come up for you
so that's
covers the nitrosamines the next one i
would like to go through is the
tetrathrotic chlorinated
dioxide endurance by isotope dilution
and using method 1613
so
method 1613 is normally run by a
magnetic sector instrument which is you
see on the bottom left-hand part of the
screen
it is very
space
intensive it takes up a lot of space in
the room it creates a lot of heat in the
room and it creates a lot of power room
you have to have circulators
to run the magnet to run the turbo pump
on the diffusion pumps uh depending on
the comp uh configuration of your system
so some of the improvements that you get
by switching to
a 7010 triple quad or msms system
is the physical size is much smaller
sits on the bench top it's very very
similar in size
to what you have traditionally had in
the 5975 or 77 slightly slightly bigger
it has lower energy consumption
uh the original purchase price is
significantly less
than a magnetic sector system if you can
still find one
the annual maintenance cost is
significantly less
and the ease of operation meaning if you
are using mass center for your single
quads for your icpms for your lcms's the
same software platform is going to apply
to all of the agilent suites of
instruments so instead of having to have
a specific person who can work on your
magnetic system systems you can now
cross-train people to work on all of the
various platforms of agilent and and
increasing the abilities of those people
increasing their career paths and
reducing your cost for having to have
multiple operators and specialized
operators to run
uh magnetic sector citizens
so gcsm gcms parameters
we're going to do a one microliter
injection we're going to follow
uh
the
wrap frames that are shown here we're
going to use a two millimeter dimpled
stopless ui injector and we're going to
use an mmi constant flow of 1.1 mils a
minute
the method specifically calls for a db5
column
so we use a db5 column with a 60 meter
0.25.25
we used our transfer line up around 350
and uh
we used the collision gas and the drying
gas
so
our mrm and collision energy parameters
are listed here
so you'll see that we have a precursor
ion and a product ion we have a quark
and a coil ion for each of the groups
uh
unlike
a lot of the methods that we've shown
here today where each compound has its
own unique transition
we only have transitions from
tetra tcd to pcbf all the way through
octa tc octa ocd and ocdf and those will
cover all of the dioxins that are within
a specific window and we'll talk about
that in just a moment
so
tetrax
through this is what we call the window
defining mix so if you're unfamiliar
with
dioxins it's the gold post
so we have the first known alluding tcd
and the last of the
known
tcd
and then we have specific tcds and tcdfs
that we look for within that region
however it also will look for any tcdd
or tcdf that falls within the region
so on the top you have the gcm sms
at the same concentration level
for the first saluter and the last
leader and then the specific uh q378 and
the one two three nine tcd and we have a
25 valley and we'll talk a little bit
more about that in a minute
and then on the bottom you'll see that
the same
gc parameters
and
using a magnetic sector system
so there's very good compatibility
between those two systems
again you have the first and the last
alluders
for uh
tcpd and this one shows the tcdf so
anything that falls within the goal post
on the left and the goal post on the
right would be counted into the totals
for tcdf in this case
uh the first solution and the last of
leaders for the
pcbs and the ecds
both on the high-risk system and on the
msms system
so in this particular case we have
specific isomers that we're looking for
within that group but also anything else
that showed up in that group that met
the qualifications as far as ion ratios
and singleton noise would be
accounted for in the system along with
just the specific
isomers
that were spiked into the sample
again here's for the pentas
and here's for the hexa so we have
specific ones that we're looking for
again anything else that would be in
there
here's the hexachloros
and then the heptachloros now the
octaves you notice there is no gold post
because there's only one ocdd and
there's only one ocdf there's nothing
that fits between there it it
encompasses all the spots on the ring
there's only one isomer that's possible
so
here is a list of the single the noise
and the response factors for what we
have for our samples and you can see our
samples
range from 200 uh ppt
up to 2.5
ppm
so the average rfs are listed on the
left the ideal is to be somewhere close
to one
uh the average rf rsvs you can see are
excellent
anywhere
from
2.4
to six
so very very accurate instrument
uh cs1s rfs right in the same ballpark
the percent differences
uh between those is eleven percent worst
case on the tcd
and
really right that on zero percent for
the hxcdf
now
i did mention that uh the retention time
criteria is monitored here and the
single to noise is also monitored
and then in this report you get a quick
reference of did you pass or fail when
you ran
your
calibration at linear range and
responses
this was run by the dow chemical company
in this particular case and they're
showing that on this specific column
you're able to achieve the resolution
that you needed
however the method does call for
a confirmation even though we can meet
the resolution criteria on this specific
column so in our case we would run a db
dioxin column um for those who have been
running dioxin for a long time it's very
similar to an
sp2331
to get
the resolution check and the isomer
specifically
between the two three seven eight ion
isomers and the one two three nine in
them
so
instrument limit of quantitations so if
you look at the limit of quantitations
for
uh
tcd for example we had a standard
deviation of 0.003
and rsd at 4.28 we had an mdl of seven
and
uh
instrument limit of quantitation and
this is in fentograms so it's just very
very small very very sensitive
instrument of 25.
and you can see we also
ran out for the other pcbs
label isomers that are on the right
the lowest again and here are the eye
ratios for the lowest calibrations as i
mentioned a little earlier uh there's a
couple criterias it has to be
for specific uh
isomers it has to meet the retention
time criteria
it has to meet the single to noise
criteria and it also has to meet the
ratio criteria which says i have to fall
within a certain window
of of the qualifier and the quantifier
to be considered a peak
and again here's the 70 can instrument
uh the idl in centigrams
so you're looking for tcdd about 5.9
a little higher for
some of the hexa compounds
and the recovery experiments for a spike
at 0.79 picograms and you can see again
we're just focusing on one for time's
sake uh
and
the 2378 because it has just the highest
toxic equivalency factor
so our uh
reps were one through six
uh point eight six point seven six point
seven six point seven six one seven one
for our rsd and seven point two so you
can see that our accuracy and precision
is very good for all the compounds and
in fact the average rsd for all
compounds was 6.7
so at 50 centigrams of 2378 tcd
uh we clearly meet the two two and a
half times single to noise ratio and in
this case it was 5.8 singles of noise
for both the qualifier and the
quantifier
uh the quantifier was 4.6 so we're able
to identify at 50 ppt
uh 50 pentagrams uh on column
okay
uh
one of the nice thing is that we have
been we have made an analyzer that has
been used in europe
for their
analysis of food and feed and along with
that it has built-in reports so you
don't have to design and create reports
we do have folks that can design and
create reports for you
on an individual basis
and you can talk to your sales folks
about that but we do have a built-in
reports into the analyzer that are going
to get you most of the information that
you're going to want
so first of all you have your initial
calibration report and you can see our
calibration report the percent rsds for
everybody this was all average
uh the worst case scenario was 15.44
and the death case was right around two
and that was for all of the labeled
compounds that we uh
inserted into the sample
uh the second one is the internal
standard and surrogate recovery reports
so you'll see here that you have the
average response factor the cc response
factor and the response factor in the
sample
so you have the ability to either
uh select
i'm going to
run my internal standards against the
average of the curve
or the continuing calibration
and then in this particular case if you
look at the right hand column
it says my area of percentage is against
the continuing calibration
and it'll say whether it's passed or
fail and the criteria generally is 50 to
150 for those criteria and you can see
that we passed for all of them except
for the cl-37 because it wasn't spiked
in the continuing calibration
so our continuing calibration report
looks a lot like the ical report but it
will tell you in this case we ran the uh
you're going to have the option of
running
and against the average response the
mid-level response or the previous
continuing calibration response
so it shows the area percentage of the
sample what the retention time was what
the difference in and in this case it
said we use the average
of the response factors of the curve to
uh present to our continuing calibration
against the average response factors
and again here's the differences right
in on the screen so
uh 19 20 16
uh for the continuing calibration
and here's the rest of the continuing
calibration because i just wanted to
include it without going over it on
every single slide so when you do get
the slide deck
you'll be able to look at the data and
if you have any questions
please feel free to ask
and this was average response for
everybody
okay here's one of the nice things that
we have already built into the custom
reports
is that you can see that we can pick out
all of the isomers that we spiked in
but we can also do the pcbs and the pcb
like compounds and add those into the
totals report for you so it's not going
to be two separate reports i can
resupport the
label compounds and i can get the toxic
equivalencies for those i can also add
the non-labeled compounds get a total
and get you the toxic equivalency for
each of those as well and those reports
are already built into your system
some of the other reports that you have
if you want to have a raw data package
so that you you can see where the
transitions are on the right
uh what ions have trans
uh transition from what to what what the
chromatography looked like and
in this case we showed the window
defining mix they showed the first and
the last
and we showed that the compounds that
fit within that window as well
so the 7010
gcms dioxin analyzer provides a complete
workflow for your laboratory
it's based on an application developed
and optimized and validated within the
european diaxial reference lab
we use the multi-mode inlet which offers
a wider range of injecting techniques
you can do small volume injections split
split lifts on column you can also do
large volume injections
uh and
uh in the in
10 20 30 4050
even higher injection volumes if you had
a need to do something like that here we
only have to shoot one mic later because
of the sensitivity of the scene of the
instrument
same g super c parameters were used for
dioxin and dioxin like pcbs
so you didn't have to have two different
methods to run the mrn transitions were
based on an application developed by and
optimized and validated and increased on
the 7010.
uh again we have the analyzer includes
the reports combining the dioxide and
the dioxin like pc fractions
and automatically perform complex
calculations required by the eu
regulations
we also have been doing work
in our lab studies here in the states
with several different laboratories
and uh we presented that at the last
nemc meeting and there will be updates
on that coming in the future
where we have run side by side real
world samples i just didn't have time
today to present that in my 25 minutes
so
if
as i said in the beginning
the instrument is far
less expensive than a mag sector
instrument which i don't think they make
anymore
it has a smaller footprint it has lower
operating costs it has lower maintenance
cost
and you're able to cross train your
analyst
to be able to move within your
laboratory as your sample flow changes
from day to day
uh these are the folks that put together
the application note
uh
that we worked with
and you can see all of their names there
i'd like to thank the people also from
agilent diana wong and craig morgan
who helped put all this testing and the
round robin studies together that made
all of this possible
i don't know how we're doing for a time
but this is the dioxin of jiren for the
another application note that we have
and if i have time i'll answer some
questions